the Joe Rogan experience boom and we're
live 12 rules for life so without
reading this so what you're saying is
there's only 12 things you need to do in
life right that's it yeah this this
interview that you just did with this
woman Kathy Newman [ __ ] was that in the
UK it was Channel 4 UK um I just went I
felt bad but I was also laughing I went
to her Twitter page to read like and in
with each one of her tweets no matter
what she says someone writes underneath
it so what you're saying is and then
some radicular mocking her but politely
non aggressively their idea I didn't
read any rude things like there was no
there was no insults or there was what
maybe a few insults but there's no
swears it was just playful mocking of
the interview that she did with you
because the interview was ridiculous it
was a ridiculous interviewing I listened
to it or watched it several times I was
like this is so strange
it's like her determination to turn it
into a conflict - it's one of the issues
that I have with television shows yeah
because they have a very limited amount
of time and they're trying to make
things as salacious as possible they
won't have these sound bites this
clickbait sound bites and she just went
into it incredibly confrontational not
trying to find your actual perspective
but trying to force you to defend a non
non realistic perspective yes well I was
that I was the hypothetical villain of
her imagination essentially well what
happened it was interesting - the way it
played itself out because I met her in
the greenroom beforehand you know she
was being made up and then they put a
little bit of powder on me and we had a
friendly kind of interchange and then we
went and sat in front of the cameras and
for a couple of minutes
you know before before the show got
rolling and we had a pretty pleasant
back-and-forth and then as soon as the
cameras went on she was a completely
different person and I thought oh I see
- Tracie what's going on yeah yeah well
so so that kind of alerted me to well
the fact that there was something rotten
in the state of Denmark let's say yeah
but you know this is also why YouTube
gonna kill TV because television by its
nature all of these narrow broadcast
technologies they rely on forcing the
story right because it has to happen now
it has to happen in like often in five
minutes because they only broadcast five
minutes of that in interview they did
put the whole thing up on YouTube to
their credit it it it hasn't ceased to
amaze me yet I think that they thought
that the interview went fine that's the
scuttlebutt I've got from sort of behind
the scenes because I've you know I know
some people who know what's going on at
Channel four and their shell shocked by
the response you know and and then of
course there is the counter response the
Guardian the next day published a paper
published an article saying that you
know the head of channel 4 had to call
in police security because of threats
you know well first of all you can call
the police and about anything and they
never did detail out exactly what the
threats were you know but then about
twenty newspapers picked that up and
went for the well Kathy Newman is now
being harassed by an army of online
trolls for doing nothing but doing her
job which well I and then there was a
backlash against that in the press and
so it's been a well what someone took an
audit of the the actual interchanges
that yep between fans and her and there
was way more negative ones coming your
way yes that were seriously negative
yeah that's right seriously negative
violent harassing just rude they're way
more yeah and no one picked up on that
at all because all the narrative was
she's a victim yeah even though she was
highly aggressive in this but you know
she's a funny victim it's not like she's
not successful yeah you know you think
you should have to hand in your victim
card I think like when you go to an Ivy
League university it's like right down
in there
yeah because you don't get to be
oppressor and oppressed at the same time
that's just too much well one of the
things you pointed out was when you were
talking about competition for very
lucrative jobs and you were saying look
what you've done
well you you must have had to work here
and she proudly was saying how
hard she had to work yeah to get there
I'm like well yes of course
no one's gonna hand this to you know
this is why on and this is why you were
saying you are opposed to equality of
outcome cause outcome we I can't imagine
anything we could possibly strive for in
our society that would make it into hell
faster than equality of outcome
[Applause]